uh daily wire has this report Target is
facing facing backlash over a designer
uh featured in the company's Pride
collection who appears to have created
products with satanic imagery
now
one thing we should note as we read on
here uh is that um anyone who's making
uh Pride anyone who's making anything
related to Pride uh the pride flag and
all that it's always it's all satanic
imagery to begin with but this is so I
think we should say that this is
explicitly satanic imagery
um Scarlett Johnson an activist from
Wisconsin went viral on Twitter this
weekend with a threat explaining why she
is done with the retailer in particular
Johnson took issue with Target listing
three items on its online store
um from
a london-based designer of products that
sometimes mix imagery and messages about
gender with the macabre none of the
three colorful apparel items for sale on
the label on Target's website have
satanic satanic imagery the catalog
includes a we belong everywhere mini
messenger bag for 18 another is a two
queer for here tote bag for eighteen
dollars and a third is a cure
transphobia not trans people sweatshirt
for 25 dollars all are listed under
Pride adult clothing
but Johnson highlighted other products
for sale that are shown on the website
for this designer and Associated
Instagram account with about 25 000
followers among them is a skeleton
draped in rainbow colors a trans witches
for abortion badge and a Satan respects
pronouns t-shirt
Johnson's thread which has been retweed
a thousand times since it began on
Saturday with many other users
criticizing Target and some even calling
for boycott others complemented the
products and questioned why Johnson had
a problem with the designer's work
the product page for the Satan respects
pronoun shirt talks about how LGBT plus
people are so often referred to as being
a product of Satan or going against
God's will while making the case that
the Church of Satan and the satanic
temple are more accepting of the gay
community
quote satanists don't actually believe
in Satan he's merely used as a symbol of
passion pride and Liberty yeah that's
that's true a lot of self-professed
satanists
don't believe in Satan
although Satan believes in them
so when we talk about Satanist within
this is why I say that leftism is
Satanism it's it they mean the same
thing
because Satanism is the worship of the
self right satanists don't explicitly or
or knowingly most of the time worship
Satan
unless they're actual theological I
guess what we call theological satanists
which most of them aren't
um rather they worship what Satan
worships which is the self
and that is also leftism leftism is the
worship of the self so really anything
associated with leftism any uh slogan
anything like that associated with
autism is satanic imagery for that
reason it's just that in this case again
it's it's explicit
now we know that Corporate America is
being held hostage by ESG the corporate
equality index and all that all these
extortion methods and that's why Bud
Light jumped on the grenade
but this kind of thing
this is not just Target checking the
woke box for the sake of getting their
score up right this is um you don't have
to promote literal outright Satanism for
that
they're doing this because they believe
it on a corporate level
this is who runs the company this is
what the company is all about
and consumers need to make a decision
based on that
president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the U.S dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
and that is gold I've bought gold for
perch gold in preparation for uncertain
Economic Times and you can trust them
too you can own gold in a tax sheltered
retirement account with the help of
Birch gold that's right Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold the best part is
they don't they you don't pay a penny
out of pocket up front when currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does a dollar have you can protect
your savings with gold Birch gold is an
A plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
you can find out why by texting Walsh to
989898 to get your free info kit on gold
again text Walsh to
989898 today you know buying a new car
can be a stressful experience for anyone
especially if you're a first time buyer
if you have no credit before you walk
into a dealership and spend the entire
day with the crowds the stress the
potential to not even find the right car
you need to check out car Zing car Zing
is completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies lenders and over 25
000 dealers Nationwide Cars Inc provides
you with everything you need before
stepping foot into a dealership you can
instantly pre-qualify online without
affecting your credit score and get
instant financing details including what
your down payment would be your monthly
payment your terms APR putting you
several steps ahead of other buyers and
once you find the right car at your
ideal budget all you have to do is bring
your save deal voucher with you to the
dealership to finalize your next ride
it's really simple takes the stress out
of it as well even if you're not in the
market for a new car you should check
out carsing anyway it's like window
shopping just poke around see what's
available in your area karzing helps
make your experience faster cheaper and
less stressful you can visit karzing.com
Walsh today to skip the guesswork and
find the best deals near you that's car
Walsh
you know we talk all the time about
how these uh you know we we shouldn't
support companies that hate us
and that's true
and it's also true that not every
company that goes woke does it
necessarily because they hate us not
that I'm defending them Bud Light does
Bud Light hate us well no they just they
they are more afraid of the left than
they are of us and so they thought that
they could throw a bone to the left and
we wouldn't do anything about it and
they and they thought wrong and we are
punishing them for that thank God
um so there is that motivation but then
in in many cases
uh in fact these are companies that
actually hate us and that's and that's
Target they truly hate us they really do
you don't put your uh Pride display
right at the front of the store you walk
into Target and it's right there
vomiting rainbows on you as soon as you
walk in you don't do that you don't sell
uh merchandise from uh designers that
make Satanist gear you don't sell
tucking underwear for children and
whatever else unless you absolutely
despise your customers and uh and they
do so what are we gonna do about it
is the question
you know I admitted with the Bud Light
thing that
although I support the boycott I help to
organize it I think it's a great thing
to continue boycotting
in spite of that I could not actually
you know I never personally participated
in the Bud Light boycott because I can't
because I was never a Bud Light customer
to begin with on the count on account of
the fact that I have functioning taste
buds so I'm you know it for me that it's
to say that I'm boycotting is just to
say that I'm gonna continue doing what
I've been doing all along which is
buying beer that actually tastes good
Target on the other hand I can boycott
because of course as a dad six kids uh
Target is convenient It's relatively
cheap at least compared to other options
um if it's like 7 30 on a Tuesday and
you realize that you need diapers or
Children's Tylenol or spaghetti sauce or
all of those things for some reason
Target is often going to be the quickest
and easiest solution depending on where
you live and it will take some measure
of actual sacrifice
to cut them out of the equation it's not
a big sacrifice it's not it's not
anything significant
they aren't going to build monuments to
commemorate the time that I I needed to
buy a swimsuit for my six-year-old and I
drove past Target and went to Walmart
instead it's not exactly a hero's
journey
but even so it requires actual
inconvenience
okay this is the kind of boycott
boycotting Bud Light this this is why
they were a good Target to begin with
um why they made such a mistake it's why
they were so vulnerable because not only
do they have
a conservative customer base but it
doesn't require any sacrifice at all to
just buy different beer you go you go to
the gas station you open up the the uh
you go to the refrigerated section you
open it up you just grab something else
that's it
but targeted you have to embrace
a little bit of inconvenience
um
and this is
this is the real test
is whether we can successfully execute a
boycott that involves inconvenience
because inconvenience is the Great
Horror of Modern Life we can't uh we
cannot endure inconvenience
that's where we draw the line usually
we'll say okay I'm with you
I'm on board
and then we hear okay it's going to
require a little bit of inconvenience
well never mind then what is it that's
crazy
what do I look like
I can't be inconvenienced
but we need to be because Target needs
to pay for this a message must be sent
and um
it just like with Bud Light it is now
it's still a boycott but it's also
they've been branded a certain way where
it's embarrassing
you know this this is why Bud Light is
probably permanently screwed because
it's now embarrassing to drink a Bud
Light it should have always been
embarrassing but now it's certainly
embarrassing and it needs to be that way
for Target like you should be
embarrassed at this point to go to
Target
um to be seen walking out of target with
those Target bags it's it's embarrassing
and that's what that's what needs to
happen here
another day for this portion of shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow
have a great day Godspeed